I you know I used to hang out with
Hedberg when I first started out oh my
gosh and we used to go do all these
shows all over the place and we both had
long hair and we were both deadpan he
was more I had a bunch of one-liner
jokes and he had all these one-liner
jokes and we kind of hung out a little
bit so we used to come stay at my house
all the time and then oh you know it's
funny is he married a girl that was at
my my very first open mic Lynn was at my
very first open mic and then I seen it
she was she was hanging out and Bonnie
McFarlane was at my very first open mic
and and you know and Lynn was hanging
out and she was kind of doing stand-up
and kind of not doing stand-up and then
and then I seen her in Toronto and she'd
been hit by a car and then I seen her in
Toronto again she'd been hit by another
car I'm like Lynn you've been hit by two
cars and she's like yeah I'm like you
gotta look both ways look one way one
way no knew it so anyway and then the
next time I see her she like she was
with me I'm like what are you open
information I'm married to him I'm like
what and then next thing I know he's
dead like I blame her
and he died on April Fool's Day and I
never believed it I thought I was fake
he was one of my favorites and like good
when I heard yeah he died I was like at
April Fool's Day there's no way that's
perfect much Hedberg and then no drugs
drugs drugs drugs drugs and just so
funny do you have a favorite like Mitch
Hedberg story or an experience you could
share I have a lot I just my big thing
that I don't know
the last time I seen him he was really
healthy and that's that's the way I want
to remember him mm-hmm he was like I was
like he was happy he was good and you
know we had a conversation and we hadn't
we hadn't had a conversation in a long
time he was it was just a mess so I was
just like a hotfoot he's doing really
well and then he was dead a couple
months later and I was like well that
was confusing so I I took I like to
remember remember him and and I just
think of him as I can remember I can see
the green room that we're in
in Montreal we're in Montreal and we're
having a it's a I think it's underground
but it's you know that's like on this
brick room and it's like old those old
like stone bricks and you know who else
was in the room but they're kind of
[ __ ] on the other side where the
flight of the conchords wrong there and
I just remember talking with me and
stuff and he was really healthy that's
what I remember about it yeah when we
think about an on stage persona versus
offstage how how similar were the two
personality pretty much pretty much yeah
okay
yeah you know I just think of him like
you know that that smile and laugh that
he did on stage it was smile and laugh
he did off stage that's you know you
know it was nice to make him laugh so
and he was more of a pen to paper guy
yeah but it was out there man it was it
wasn't it wasn't sit down and write down
it was hey you know those were his
thoughts those were real thoughts that
that was that wasn't that wasn't pushing
for a joke that just came out naturally
you know which I love I love unforced
humor and he was not forced at all you
know I mean how early into your career
did you guys connect um I was told
living in Vancouver was before he moved
to New York Oh
from the beginning oh my god I want to
say 93 I want to say 93 and you know who
else was around and and he only told me
a couple years ago cuz I thought I had
met him in New York when I first met him
was Brody Stephens was hanging around
Vancouver Wow so yeah I don't know what
my eyes are starting to tear up just
thinking about that uh I don't know why
I don't even know either of them but you
I guess when you're in like the comedy
world well it's so connected to the your
peers in a sense even if you didn't know
them yeah I see what you're saying
yeah it's it's a pretty small world are
the staff it's grown a lot but it's
still pretty small it's
when when you hear a name and you don't
know who it is and stand up you're like
well that's interesting
hey hot brother and sister thanks a lot
for watching this video if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath click the subscribe button to
join the hop read the verse and then
watch more videos to get even more
comedy tips and stop sucking at comedy
go ahead click it